hello everyone welcome back to a big
mood big mood today we have one of our
favorite husbands uh on deck here he's
my favorite husband
nice to be included steve [ __ ] steve
steven paul green
thank you very much for using my full
legal name please cut that number
and make sure you spell it with a ph so
it's like
make sure you bully him about it that's
fine wait is it really spelled with a ph
yeah it's very annoying anytime i sign
up for anything
and they read it back to me i'm like
whatever it's stefan stefan
so we have stefan on set here who else
do we have on set you got gina on set
you got nikki on set and then of course
me jess
all sad yeah i mean i feel like the
consolation prize is
so today i wanted to talk about red pill
boys
and i wanted to bring a guy on because i
know the guys are going to be like
you don't even have a male perspective
you know
so we have representation here for you
little [ __ ] um
i'm very red we actually get we get we
get this request a lot or we used to in
the comments
is it the same as mgtow the there that's
a part of the community okay
there's there's a million little
shoot-offs um we can get into the
spectrum of friends
there's a ton of [ __ ] within the
manusphere manosphere online
okay interesting so i guess um since a
lot of people
who are not obsessed with the internet
might not know exactly what
this community is i'll try to explain it
a little bit um i gotta get a woman
explain us
no i got all of this stuff off the
internet okay so if
written by men okay like wikipedia
[ __ ] like that so basically where we
need to start is understanding what the
mana sphere
is which is a collection of websites and
online forms promoting masculinity
strong opposition to feminism very often
hostility towards women
and even quite also often exaggerated
misogyny so
this is just a section of the internet
where a lot of guys go to vent
the manosphere has been associated
sometimes with the politically
far-right or alt-right and even little
pieces are
associated with white supremacist groups
but that's not the main part
but it basically it's just a radical
space of the internet that a lot of men
have gone to there's different groups
within it there's in cells we know the
involuntary celibates they're part of
the manosphere
mgtow which is men going their own way
is a part of the manosphere pickup
artists are part of the manosphere
we know how gina feels about oh yeah
and then there's also like father's
rights groups yeah oh
so those i i feel like they're the ones
that had a legitimate start
right
they wanted to go vent somewhere they
wanted help from other men like how do i
[ __ ] deal with this shitty divorce
yeah so it makes sense like kind of a
lot of men being
sort of upset with like just the world
in general or like
dealing with females like they need
somewhere to go to like it's like the
one part of the justice system i've
i've seen like women kind of have an
unfair advantage of but
there's so many other parts where women
get but it's still sexist right she
didn't understand
funny thing about it yeah it has to be
funny because otherwise everything's
suffering
is that the judge is like well obviously
the woman would raise the child better
yeah i mean the judges are usually men
and don't men write most of our laws so
i don't know y'all figure it out but
anyways
the manosphere so the manosphere is
often seen as a negative thing i want to
give it
some room for it to not be just a
[ __ ] pile so we can we can kind of
discuss like the first
specs of it yeah like hear them out like
what i mean obviously i think with any
community
there's always going to be crazy radical
people that take things too far
but the community typically communities
typically start for a reason like a lot
of people are feeling the same way about
something and they just want to feel
like someone else hears them out or
whatever so while initially
um any type of crazy feminist or
whatever is probably going to be mad
that i even give them
any benefit of the doubt at all giving
them a platform yeah yeah but i i
do and i you know i've been seen as a
lately a little bit of a man hater so i
want to give a little bit of space to
understand uh
men's issues as well and i'm not just a
man hater like i've been talking a lot
of [ __ ] about men lately
um but i do think that there there's
obviously
a lot of good men that still deserve to
um live so
oh that's good yeah can this one stay
in the middle you're one of one of them
the spot in the middle is that a few men
deserve to live
a couple i feel like that's with any
extremist group like it started from a
decent place a logical place like um
like religion even
religion has been known to go extreme
and like could be very toxic and not and
problematic but
um what it started as is like uh you
know a good place like it's like it's
like people want a
sense of community and they want to put
love into the world and light and i feel
i think a lot of religion still holds
that place for people
right but then there's we just hear the
extremist groups that
are like either the crazy christians or
islam
uh radicals or whatever but that's not
the main core
thing but as far as the manosphere goes
i mean a lot of it is kind of just
a lot of like hate so i wouldn't say
that they started from a place of light
but i would say that like i don't think
it's necessarily all
bad at the same time either the place of
coping right right
so um what i found someone described on
the internet that the main tenets of the
manosphere can be reduced to two main
points which is
the corruption of modern society by
feminism uh which
basically is in direct violation of the
differences between men and women like
feminism doesn't take into account that
there are differences between men and
women
and secondly that the ability of men to
save society or achieve sexual prowess
by adopting
a hyper-masculine role and forcing women
to submit to them so
it is pretty um misogynistic i would say
corner of the world slightly
a little slightly misunderstood um and
it kind of seems to boil down that men
are the victims
for something so that's why a lot of
times people don't respect this
yeah because they don't like to see
minutes so what do you think well so
this is interesting right because
i'm of two minds about it like i can i
can zoom out and just
point at the extremist guys and laugh
and i often do i think we all do
especially when we hear certain stories
about them
and like a lot of the incel stories were
like they're like [ __ ] all women they're
all
like awful all that stuff we all tend to
laugh at all that stuff but we don't
tend to
peek behind the curtain and try to look
at what's going on yeah and
um yeah so i think that the idea so
let's break it down right so you got the
idea that feminism
has infected society so that i as a man
have to go
i cannot um be a man as much
now ruin traditional values i'm supposed
to be something different
i'm supposed to almost kind of go away
because like
you know the future is women right now
right and like
[ __ ] yeah it is so right so stuff like
that makes people go oh
okay well i'm not a woman i have
literally no chance of doing that
of being part of the future i guess so i
guess what i'll do
is kind of just recede into my own
little um
place my own little hovel where maybe
other people
agree with me that this has kind of
gotten out of hand a little bit
like i think all the futures women stuff
is just super [ __ ] lame
if anything like it's just like
sloganeering and it doesn't really
i think it's like the way people take it
so yeah because
you can take it one way like oh if
you're not female get the [ __ ] out
because you're not in the future
or you can take it as like we've been
told like we're kind of been a less than
um gender for so long that it's like hey
it doesn't have to be that way there's a
future for us
like there's two different and that's
ways you can interpret and that's that's
what i like about it right
about the sloganeering i don't like all
the like this rhymes and so therefore
it's like really good and like
like you know like um the future's
female so like they're marketing baby
it's just super it's just not a good
argument for me i'm like cool what about
it
is should be female let's go there like
let's talk about it well first what
we're to do is we're going to kill all
the men
and then well yeah okay
we need to find the good specimens first
uh extract them with their sperm because
we still need to
you know populate but then then we burn
all of them we just like figure out that
instead
so we can create sperm yeah that window
where like the male sperm die
because they're faster but they live
shorter because the women's sperm
continue to live
i can see that then we'll inseminate
during that period anyways
that's that's what i'm saying right
where it's like if you look at
everything right and they're going
we need more women here we need more
girls for this and all that stuff and
you're you're going well i'm not that so
i won't be a part of it i need to go
somewhere where maybe
other people does anybody agree with me
well they don't out here
oh they did on my facebook group but
then facebook decided to ban it because
they say we're misogynist [ __ ] right
and then now i got to go somewhere else
so where do i go i go to maybe reddit
red pill
i go to maybe 4chan and then i'm
surrounded by
by people who are even further out on
the limb and they're they're [ __ ]
you know blowing around hard like
obviously extremist people
they're more of them and i'm bouncing my
thoughts off the victims
indoctrinated and that's what happens
yeah and so we can choose to
look at it and ridicule and laugh and go
ha ha they're so stupid
how great are we that we all just agree
with each other over here or we can try
to treat them
like people yeah and and try to figure
out what's going on if i had a kid
and they were going through something
and they lashed out at school
beat some kid up and i bring them home
and i'm like
[ __ ] you you beat a kid up that's [ __ ]
up no
like you could never hurt another person
obviously we all agree with that
does anybody disagree with that but if i
was to be
at any layer of maturity deeper than
just punishing someone i would try to
sit them down and be like what's going
on
like what makes you feel like you need
to do that to somebody else well i'm
like getting emotional
well we don't do that a lot you know
some people just need to be understood
yeah man and so you know i can take
myself there and
you know because like my god my my
background was all comedy so i can
if i want to i can just break anything
[ __ ] down
and like attack it with a war arsenal
and that's fun
and it's fun for everybody like if you
look at look at our news right now look
at look at
our late night comedy right if you want
to go
watch the news some people watch it
through late night comedy are you
getting the news from late night comedy
like of course not you're getting the
arsenal the war arsenal
like just launching on people getting
sound bites that you can use later
and beating on jokes because it's it's
supposed to be for jokes it's small
clips of small truths to hit a punch
line hit the stereotype hit the trope
hit the meme about it and then let's all
laugh and move on and that's healthy
and that's good too apparently yeah well
but there's a healthy aspect to it right
that's your only um exactly exposure to
what's going on in our culture or
whatever then it's not a full picture
so it's not giving people enough
information
there hasn't been room for discussion
right yeah and if you
if you're now a man right and you're
told well if i
want to you know be
you're not told to be responsible for
yourself not anymore not really
i mean you hear a lot of like well
that's toxic to to try to do that or you
want to pay for the
woman's food that's a toxic old world
way of thinking
obviously the woman should be able to
pay for the food and
the ideas behind that have been mixed in
with this
like the shitty people right the shitty
ones who are toxic
like get mixed in with like the guys who
are like no i just want to
show them that i want to take care of
them
not that they need me to take care of
them that's actually something i agree
with like if a guy
expects me to pay for a first date i'm
like well then you're not even here to
like set up a relationship like what are
you what are you what are we doing here
what is this game
yeah and see unfortunately the red bill
guys some of them
and or the black pill guys more more of
those guys so i would say the black
pills are the
incels the ones that like just can't
like can't
get laid women are all [ __ ] you have
to pay them for sex
yeah yeah and i and they know that
because they've only been able to pay
women to have sex with them
and so they're like all women need to be
paid for sex see what happens like
that's it's a wild thing it's circular
reasoning it's like
well all women need to be paid for sex
because that's the only way i've ever
had sex so i need to pay for sex without
you and you just this they shame those
women they're shaming what they're
actively consuming
yeah which is because they feel shame
it's projected projection
but they yeah they also have things like
where they're like yeah you have to be
x height like you have to be this amount
of height or else a woman won't [ __ ] you
yeah you have to make x amount of money
or else won't [ __ ] you
yeah they're they're creating these like
these uh i mean there's a stuff that we
talk about like these little online
definitions and then they set up like
this is the way the world is so like in
the manosphere
there's this thing where they they
divide men into alpha and beta males
where alphas are seen as sexually
dominant and attractive to women
and women are hardwired to want sex with
alphas
and that but they believe that women
will only pair with beta males for
financial stability or financial
benefits so if you're not the the super
hot guy the super strong super tall
super handsome
um you can get laid that way or if
you're quote unquote a beta male you
have to be rich and that's how you'll
get
laid so that they believe they just put
all men into your either alpha or beta
and then
but i just don't think that's even
realistic but turn on real housewives
there's a lot of confirmation bias if
you just watch that show and you're like
holy [ __ ] that's how the world works
i understand i mean so i feel there's so
many
similarities between the feminist
movement and and this movement were like
radical movements yeah the radical
movements yeah um where
like women were getting sick of being
like there's a group that's like well
you have to either have
you know big boobs and be really sexy
and then you get the guy
or or like you have to be the popular
girl to get the guy
or you have to like be you know make
good food or
be a good you know whatever like be a
domestic pers spouse
and so it feels like a little bit of
like separating like you're either this
or that
yeah what is that a false dichotomy like
what is the the that argument yeah it's
a false dichotomy where it's like either
this or that
right there's no in between yeah yeah
yeah and that's that's what's going on
right and then you have
so then you have both groups sort of
shouting at each other across the street
and nobody's meeting halfway and nobody
wants to have a conversation anymore
it's all just
i have my slogan and you have your
slogan well i say the future's female
well i say all women are [ __ ]
and they all wanna are gold diggers and
and there's no
you never make progress that way and so
and because we've
banned places that maybe had a couple
bad eggs
who were um you screenshot the bad egg
and then facebook goes we're taking down
this community because
it has sexism or whatever misogyny you
push these people to dark corners of the
internet and then you are surprised at
the result
you create martyrs and then the martyrs
get more radical and then people are
just like they
it just spirals downward or they try to
destroy people who
are asking questions or being reasonable
like jordan peterson they've done
nothing but try to destroy that man
since he came out
and all he was talking about is how men
go into their own like pleasure islands
because they feel like they can't
participate or they're not appreciated
but in their groups or in their in
society
and so they they go to you know play
video games all day or they go
watch online porn all day or they go you
know wherever to just get
some kind of gratification feel like
they can get pleasure from something
and then they end up just binging on all
of that stuff
get into substance abuse problems all
that kind of [ __ ] because
nobody's actually saying are you okay
and nobody wants to because
you're a man you're not supposed you're
supposed to already have it all figured
out
you don't need help you're not supposed
to ask for help you're not supposed to
get therapy because that's kind of lame
and and that's all girl stuff right if
you're raised to think all that
like whether it's just by shitty parents
maybe one parent not being in the
household or or just
you know some kind of a cultural thing
that you've had from
growing up with with with parents who
came from somewhere else where that was
very common
that creates all kinds of problems that
we don't
talk about we just laugh at instead and
so we'll just pull clips and then we'll
say
see how stupid these guys are oh toxic
masculinity that's toxic masculinity at
everything
instead of going like what what's really
going on right now
if i have a problem with nikki we get
into arguments or something
we we don't just sit there and talk
about the argument we we try to peek
behind the curtain and find out what's
going on yeah like what was the
intention behind
the argument or we would never make
progress yeah healthy
that's everything and that's how you we
have to choose
as a as a i hate saying as a society so
much but that's
all we have as a community i mean
whatever uh as people
to if we want to actually make progress
on problems
we have to actually treat them like
their problems or and
also come at it where hey we're both on
the same same team trying to figure out
the solution
yeah you're not just the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that i'm talking to and i hate [ __ ]
so why am i talking to [ __ ] and why
would i
mm-hmm but that's because a lot of the
feminist movement the
the healthy portion that's like hey you
know uh
they're talking about the patriarchy is
not just oppressing women but also
teaching men to not be able to um
deal with these problems like you know
the the patriarchy and this
i'm just saying in quotes because i'm
this is just what from what i've heard
is that it it's also responsible for
creating
the toxic masculinity and making it feel
it making you making these people feel
like they can't go to therapy
because that's a weak thing yeah that's
all part of what they're trying to
dissemble but then
you know what happens is there's always
extremists so then
you get the feminists or the extremists
feminists that
are like [ __ ] all men anyway you know
and so then these
these red pill guys are like see
feminists and [ __ ] all men like i'm
still i can't ever
like be be vulnerable and they criticize
each other's thinking but they
are the same way dude i read um two
separate articles on
how like one was from feminists that was
like marriage only benefits the man
and one was from the red pill guys it's
like marriage only benefits the women
they both think that the system is set
up to
only serve that segment of society and
it's it's sad because we can't just talk
about it but you know what's even sadder
is being
really hungry like you like you're
[ __ ] hungry and you're like i don't
even have time to cook i don't even have
ingredients to cook
you know what would help you in your
life is doordash
uh doordash is an app and they are
sponsoring us so thank you for that
doordash
um they connect you with restaurants
that you love right now you don't have
to wait
it's right to your door and you can get
groceries essentials
as well not just restaurants but if you
need groceries girl
guy they got you um you can get drinks
snacks other household items delivered
in under an hour
ordering is easy you just open up the
app you choose what you want from where
you want and your items will be left
safely outside your door
with the contact list delivery drop-off
setting so you don't have to you don't
have to touch nobody you don't want to
talk
to nobody they just drop it off at your
door there's over 300 000 partners in
the u.s puerto rico canada
and australia and you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeyes
chipotle and cheesecake factory
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code mood that's 25
off up to a 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code mood
don't forget that's code mood for 25 off
your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply do you
need someone to talk to
but you don't really want to talk to
your friends i got you
we have talkspace um i recommend
talkspace for therapy it's an online
therapy app that i actually used to use
before
and it's great because you feel like you
always have someone there
to vent to to dump all your feelings out
to um you can sign up online and start
therapy the same day as you sign up
you can text video or send voice
messages to your licensed therapist
because sometimes you're crying too hard
and you don't want to type so it's
incredibly convenient to have virtual
sessions from the comfort of your home
it's also insanely affordable talk space
is a fraction of the cost of
in-person therapy instead of waiting for
an appointment you can send unlimited
messages to your therapist 24 7 and
they'll engage with you daily
five days a week that when when i used
it like i would be going through things
at like two in the morning
and i don't want to wait until the next
session to talk to a therapist i just
dump it all out
i can do it on voice message if i want
to and they respond to you
talkspace has thousands of licensed
therapists with years of experience in
over 40 specialties including depression
anxiety substance abuse trauma anger
management and relationship issues food
and eating and so much more
talkspace is secure and private using
the latest end-to-end bank grade
encryption technology to store client
information
as a listener of our podcast you'll get
100 off your first month with talkspace
to match with the licensed therapist
today go to talkspace.com
make sure to use the code mood to get a
hundred doll hairs off your first month
and show your support for the show
that's mood at talkspace.com to get a
hundred dollars off your first
month that's a lot of doll hair so many
doll hairs
100 um going back to the whole
i kind of want to touch a little bit on
that idea of like um how feminists think
marriage only benefits the man and women
think
that or sorry the opposite hardcore
opposite thinks that it only benefits so
can you i guess steve give us the uh
hardcore
red pill explanation why guys think
marriage only benefits
wait yes woman may i ask first though
because
what is the difference between a red
pill and a black pill
so there's pills there's a whole bunch
of pills there's like brown green
whatever there's like a
rainbow of pills they don't actually
there's no actual pills they don't exist
it comes from the matrix right there's a
scene where you get the blue pill or the
red pill
so the blue pill is you just kind of
stay in whatever fat like what the
fabricated world that we kind of you
know
stay programmed right and then the red
pill is like you
you you get to wake up the real truth of
the world and i guess so what they think
the real truth of the world is that
feminism is ruining and blah blah blah
so black pill is the more those are the
guys that can't get laid at all like the
incels are typically the black pills so
like red pill guys are like they can
still get chicks or whatever but they're
just pissed about them
yeah and then there's like brown pill
purple pill
green pill like you gotta go look up all
of the other pills i mean they they just
have their pharmacy back there
they have their own things that they're
more obsessed with like some are more
obsessed with like
the elite society is ruining the world
some are more obsessed with like
see i can get on that train yeah so
there's there's a whole bunch of
different there's an alien one i think
so i think the green pill
maybe don't don't go looking at me it's
already bad i want to
join you come home indoctrinated right
did you know
the feminist movement is hiding aliens
all she had to do is watch a couple
videos and she became
a vegan for a little while so yeah that
was be careful very emotionally
traumatic speaking of slaughtering
animals cults and [ __ ] anyway i'm just
kidding i'm kidding i love you
so red pigs like animals red pill is
kind of like normal guys that have
relationships with women a lot
so even i think i believe one of the the
more popular moderators of the red pill
was actually in a relationship
at some point she says with a girl in
canada she says
right no but she's from another school
you guys probably don't know yeah yeah
yeah
you've never seen her so i would say the
guys that like never [ __ ] get laid
that like
literally have to pay for prostitutes
are probably the black pill guys okay
yeah and they're the guys who are
unfortunately
obsessed with the idea of being
masculine
to the point where they talk about it so
much that it it it makes them seem
really weak
yeah and and that's what i think they're
missing in the way that they do all this
the lack of self-awareness yeah
so going back to like how what what do
these red pill guys think why do they
think that marriage only benefits women
and not them so alimony
right so we're talking about divorce
though but well no but
you're tied into with somebody and then
if if they can just leave you which is
their plan
ultimately the whole time like in a way
it's always agenda-based yeah
um and then they'll leave you and then
they get to take half of everything that
you worked for
um and then there's the idea too that um
they
they got with you for that and it's
funny too because
they trapped you they they trapped you
but i do know somebody who went through
that
where literally on the year where she
qualified for alimony she filed for
divorce
so like it does happen but they choose
to look at it and go
that happens to everybody that's the
only scenario does this happen to me or
my friend
that's why does it exist it's the
ultimate truth yes it's existed a few
times and they'll hold it over your head
like
well try and divorce me then like you do
what i want or else i'll divorce you
don't take all your money
it's so black and white with them
there's no in between yeah yeah and
that's but
but we all fall for it with different
topics right it just depends so yeah
you have to try to remember that as as
we talk about even different things
that it's so easy to snap judgment and
just clap back and be like
that's so [ __ ] stupid but if we want
to actually try
it happening yeah but if we exactly but
if we want to try to solve
problems we have to dig in a little
deeper sometimes than we do
right especially right now where it's
like well you're canceled and like
i don't even know why you brought up
like look what happened to jordan
peterson it's like
he's bringing up that men should be
talked about
well i think jordan got cancelled for
his views on trans
gender issues but there's a lot there's
a lot of reasons why he's been
because he's anti-trans he's not by the
way right but that's what that's what
i'm saying where
you can just take somebody what they're
trying to say
warp it into what they're not saying and
then destroy them for what they're not
saying and then
then it and then if you like jordan
peterson
now you're viewed as an alt-right person
and then you
are like wait was that where i belong
what the [ __ ] so it's all just
you're not even allowed to listen to a
discussion or else now you're getting
lumped in with it
or say that you listen to it uh-huh like
that's just
wild as hell to me yeah but it's hard to
understand the other side i remember i
had one person on my facebook that was
very uh right-wing and we had very
opposite
beliefs and i reached out to him i was
like hey like i don't want to attack you
but
i really do want to understand the other
side you know like i want to hear your
side so there's a reason why they
believe that
so you kind of want to know why right
yeah yeah and we had a healthy
discussion about it i mean later on he
turned out to be [ __ ] racist as [ __ ]
but i feel like it's healthy to to
understand the other side totally
yes yeah and then so i guess on the
feminist
on the hardcore feminist side of you
know marriage only benefits
men in their point of view because i've
read some of it
i don't necessarily agree with this but
um in their point of view
they think that um you know men are
very much served by a woman like she
makes sure the house is in order
she's like the mate she's like the free
mate kind of tip not free but obviously
you're paying for her to live there but
like the free maids
these are expectations housekeeper yeah
so like she'll cook she'll clean she'll
raise a kid she'll do everything for you
so you can have
this family life which benefits you in
society so that you can go out and work
she has to take your name yeah so she's
basically serving you her whole life and
then what happens
that i guess pisses off a lot of women
is that they'll trade down for a younger
girl right so they're like i'm going to
give him my whole life served him my
whole life and then he's just going to
trade down for another
for a younger model of the barbie so i'm
just spending my whole life and serve
and then he
kicks me out when i'm old and no one's
going to want me so there's
you can see why you know those
circumstances have happened so like the
woman's now fit 52 or something like
she's her blown out from kids you know
like she's done
she's by the way if you're 52 it's yeah
it's not this is not true but like
this is how it feels yeah exactly though
then you should be worried
exaggerated statement like women are
made to feel like when they've had
they're in their 50s they've had their
kids they're no longer desirable anymore
so like
my husband's just going to trade down
the marriage benefited him and he's
going to get married again
they see evidence of that because guys
are doing that yeah so but is that
every marriage no is that like five
percent of them
definitely probably there's also too
much outside looking in right like if
i'm a hardcore feminist and i look at a
housewife and i'm like ugh
like i pity you mm-hmm you don't know
that this person is suffering or any of
that kind of [ __ ]
she could like that she does that my mom
was a housewife my mom [ __ ] loved
raising kids my mom was a is a genius at
raising kids
you watch my mom with kids it's
incredible i don't think it's about them
hating the house life i think it's like
the anger that comes from like oh you
spent your whole life doing that and
then now you get
you get traded in for a new model no i'm
not talking about that though i'm
talking about the ones who do the ones
who
are the ones who see being a house
little housewives yeah we actually just
talked about this in the last episode
where like
um why can't we just let women choose
and i feel like the heart of the
feminist movement is just like letting
women choose
the original yeah but then there's
extremists
that are like you shouldn't be doing
anything for
a man and you should be wanting to do
have your own career your own life and
like the housewife is like
i want this life that i i chose this
life and that's like
incoming fire from other feminists right
or from other women
yeah and then for guys if you want to be
a stay-at-home dad you get incoming fire
from
the from the from guys yeah like lame
and like that's like like feminine not
manly right or even the way that i talk
when i came into jk i remember some of
the guys saying that
that i have a feminine feminine
perspective and i'm like that's not
you just because you're in touch with
your emotions right yeah i'm asking
questions i'm interested
in what people are thinking but but
but unfortunately people get wired to
think that
doing that is feminine and really it's
just you're just trying to
understand people so but we do all this
to everything we slap labels on and go
male female like women manly masculine
feminine
very extreme in asian households too men
are not like
men are not allowed to experience that
feel any sort yeah
feel any sort of emotion um express any
sort of emotion like that's not manly
this is not manly this is not manly and
i remember
hearing it in my family all the time
like this is not manly this is not
feminine and stuff you know and so then
i grew up and i
realized that a lot of men have very
suppressed emotions have no idea how to
show them and when they do
they get called out for being like a
little [ __ ] or something punished yes
yeah
yeah yeah there's some quote i saw
somewhere about like either whether
violent
in person or like your height they're
hiding some sort of violence because
they're just they
have nowhere to put it whether they
actually go out and shoot someone or
they're hiding it in their head and
they're like
online like they're like a lot of men
are just like hiding some sort of
violence and it's going to erupt in some
way
yeah i don't know this emotion is scary
in both men and women
like if you suppress your emotions as a
woman it could come out
in so many other different ways probably
not as violent maybe promiscuous
maybe yeah yeah you could drown your
kids i mean there's always there's a few
of those yeah there's definitely some
some women that have lost it and killed
their kids but
i've heard some really just strange
standards for men that i've
you know throughout my life like men
aren't supposed to speak as much it's
like
what the [ __ ] really yeah who said that
asian households like men
shouldn't speak as much they keep their
emotions inside and they just work and
that's it like you don't need to say
about their emotions but because men are
men
men have the platform to speak on
[ __ ] everything yeah you know but
maybe not
so emotional yeah like for my dad
example he was raised like that you know
um it wasn't until the last like maybe
five ten years that he was able to
actually express more because it was
always i'm a man i keep it inside i
don't speak men don't speak much men go
to work they bring money home that's it
and
i've met other men who are just like
they finally break down like i dated a
guy who finally broke down he's like
everyone just expects so much of me i
can't say anything i can't do anything
and it's heartbreaking all these people
you don't even in the center the places
that you're talking about where
men are heard right usually they're not
talking about what's going on under
under there they're talking about sports
talking about
like whatever [ __ ] political thing
like late night comedy whatever they're
not talking about
men like that's what's that's what's
interesting is
there's no place to like i mean until
joe rogan came along really yeah there
was nowhere to go
where it's like hey this is what guys
are like and this is like
how men are and if you're in that weird
transition point like between being a
like a teen or a young man and i'm
trying to be a man like
how how do i do that it tells them what
they're supposed to do right and if
you're raised in a household without a
father or without a father who like
is worth a damn yeah or he's always
working or there's some reason why
the males aren't getting much
information passed down i
like i've to this day i can still ask my
guy friends like
when you are going through something
like emotionally or maybe like a breakup
or a family death or something
who do you go to open up to and a
majority of them
be like no one i kind of just keep to
myself
and it's just that's not healthy you
know but we're encouraged to
yeah but they're encouraging you even
when you're even when you've been raised
that way though and then now someone
tries to encourage you to it's almost
like you don't even know how cause like
i feel like i've tried that with my dad
like i'm like can
like try to get him to open up because i
can see him hurting about this or that
but
and maybe it's because i'm his daughter
too he won't tell me [ __ ] but i just
feel like
like asking men to do that also they're
probably like wait
i don't even know where to start i can't
even do that i go to try to get there
and i and my reflexes don't right you
know what i'm saying like it's just
something that you're
that you're just shown like from every
example that you see like whether it's
in your own household or
in media or anything it's guys don't cry
we don't want to talk about our feelings
and
like we're [ __ ] either we're
superheroes
or we're the weird [ __ ] guy
in uh the night crawler
you know what i mean like like it's and
then there's a lot of in between like
you're a kevin james and you're the fat
guy with a hot wife
that's like i like that guy right he's
sick
but that's i think that guy though is a
little bit more healthy because he
processes pain through humor
so at least it's like getting processed
a little bit you know like it's just
you know it's at least coming out but
the the ones i'm scared of are the ones
that never
address anything or and i just think
that we all need to be better at
listening to that right just like
when somebody is lashing out instead of
doing this thing like why are you being
so dramatic or why are you
like doing this trying to figure out
what's going on behind there
it has changed everything for me like
personally just
like doing that with you all the time
like like i have no resentment with you
ever yeah see because we figure it out
yeah i mean steve had a breakthrough on
our we have on our patreon we have a
[ __ ] they don't tell you after dark
which is a bonus episode of our
regular podcast and we it's kind of more
intimate and it's kind of more
um like things that we haven't
all the way figured out yet we're going
through it and i remember you like
having a breakthrough of realizing that
you cried because you were like
you didn't realize you were depressed
because every time i ask you it's like
the reflex is like no i'm fine
but i don't want to show you that but
really like there's some [ __ ] underneath
there that's like [ __ ] i am depressed
yeah and it was like a safe space to
actually get to process that well she
asked me she's like you know you do
what do you do for yourself yeah and i
was like i don't do anything for myself
and that's when i was like oh [ __ ] and i
you know i broke down about it because
that's
and i think that that is happening out
there to a lot of a lot of men women
everybody like what do you
you know if you are a person who
gets fulfillment from helping friends or
family members or whatever
if you don't help yourself then it's
inevitable that you're on the downward
slope
in a depression cycle you're just giving
and you're not filling back up your cup
yes yeah and that's where i went is i
just didn't
have the ability to fill my own cup up
because i was like well i'll get the
little hits of
dopamine that i get from helping you out
or helping friends out
and not doing anything for me and i
think that if that goes unrecognized for
too long
that i could see how a guy would build
resentment like
i'm just giving and giving and giving
and no one ever gives to me and i don't
because they're not giving to themselves
we ridicule them yeah we ridicule them
but we say it's toxic masculinity
to be a certain type of man right now
um but literally a whole part of our
society
functions on the backs of men working
like when there's a storm and your power
goes out
who do you think it is who takes that
risky job
like statistically it's it's going to be
a guy
because women statistically don't want
to do like that riskier
like job to their own like safety and
yes of course there are women who do it
yeah but they're exceptions to every
role it's like it's technically it or
statistically physically it's going to
be a guy out there but we don't
look at that and say thank you we don't
look at that and think that's good
we go we live in a patriarchal society
where men are all bad and
and and everything that men set up every
masculine aspect
our culture got set up by men and it's
all bad to be a man so stop doing that
raise your kids as not
men like don't teach them manly things
or responsibility
and then be shocked at the result yeah
and i think that that's what
a lot of these communities are are mad
about yeah i mean
and that's understandable i think um
whenever
there's a an imbalance there's an over
correction that happens first
and i think that's kind of maybe what
we're experiencing now we're seeing now
and
you know if you zoom out nobody knows
what the [ __ ] they're doing
other generations [ __ ] [ __ ]
themselves up and then now we're
we're trying to figure out and correct
their mistakes and so then we end up
[ __ ] ourselves up and then the next
generation has to
fix our mistakes and um and it's just
like super masculine
yeah and so it's just it's there's an
over correction period where there
there was like a long [ __ ] history of
like
well we didn't get to women didn't get
to vote we had to like do everything our
husbands said we
we couldn't we literally couldn't get a
job go to cooking
yeah we slept across we weren't supposed
to speak we were just supposed to be
baby makers that raised the kids and
know how to make a good meal
and keep our man happy and so there's
yeah there's like
a movement that was like hey i don't
want that to be my life
i like i i'm actually interested in
science can i go like be a [ __ ]
astronaut like is there
a space for me there a space um
but like yeah so so then it's like this
healthy movement started where it's like
okay cool we got voting rights now we
can go you can open up a bank account
yeah i can buy a house we got equal
rights
every time now she's making me very
uncomfortable but then what happened
yeah i think i think i don't have to
make sandwiches does that hurt you
i make sandwiches because i want to not
because i have to i have to
i make the bed because i want to not
because i have to
and i use high quality bed sheets from
attitude that was really good
i like that good job the dirty little
not-so-secret about the bedding aisle is
that the cotton
might be the most popular fabric for
sheets duvets and pillowcases but
it's damaging to our planet apparently
into your hair
cotton oh yeah silk sheets are better
for the hair um so we wanted to
introduce you guys to editude
um i love these sheets they feel so soft
you can tell when uh someone has nice
sheets versus when they have those cheap
sheets that's a game changer yeah it
feels different you feel rich when you
go to sleep just feels good
it's comfy it's cool these are attitude
is the anti-cotton
unlike cotton which consumes massive
amounts of water energy and chemicals
during production attitude uses organic
bamboo which is the most
resource efficient plant on the planet
it's so soft
they're so comfortable etitudes 100
organic bamboo fabric has a unique
silky smooth and feathery soft texture
that is it does kind of feel like silk
but it's not silk yeah
it feels very soft it's like softer than
silk it's
yeah it's amazing their passion to
provide the best quality sleep in the
most sustainable way
etitude's organic bamboo fabrics are
temperature regulating hypoallergenic
antibacterial
and toxin free and we know guys don't
like to wash their sheets so maybe try
attitude sheets you won't you know and
that's the type of
old guys that's all guys literally not
one guy has ever washed a sheet it's
definitely
a true trophy every guy has always had
that remember that the
the t-shirt fabric from target
yeah no matter what pills yeah
fabric try attitude betting for 30
nights if you're not completely
satisfied return it for a full refund
okay right now you can get twenty
percent off your order plus free
shipping when you visit edit2.com
mood and enter our code mood remember
that's
attitude as in eco attitude
order today for free shipping and twenty
percent off your order
mood with promo code mood so they know
we sent you
also shout out to noom if you want to
correct your habits if you want to get
healthy and stay healthy you need to
know more about how you
make decisions not just making that you
that you make decisions but like how do
you make those decisions
and what nuum does is it gives you the
knowledge tools and confidence to make
strategic choices that turn into
long-term habits
you know little by little you can change
how your life flows by changing
these little habits so specific goals
you want to achieve
and you like you can figure out the
psychology behind it and then
incorporate that into your life whether
it's physical which is like eating
better to feel better
having more energy psychological like an
improved sense of self-worth
or a social uh type of thing where like
you feel
more confident in a crowd um with nume
it's
it's easy and convenient it's just 10
minutes a day and the tone of the
program
works with your lifestyle so you don't
have to commit to a rigorous plan just
10 minutes a day
that's everyone that's got 10 minutes a
day come on it's based on psychology and
neum teaches you why you make the
choices you do and gives you the tools
to replace your habits with healthier
ones
they use cognitive cognitive behavioral
approach so that just sounds fancy and i
just believe it
because it sounds like oh that's science
don't fix me
it means it's not just improving your
health you're actually gaining the
knowledge and habits you need to stay
healthy
there's a science to getting healthier
it's called noom sign up for your trial
today at noomnoom.com
big mood learn how to get healthy with
noom sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com big mood
ready to learn how to live healthier
sign up for noom today at noom.com
big mood big mood we give you guys so
many discounts
man i know you're welcome and also thank
you for our sponsors
yeah yeah money that you saved venmo me
yeah stupid
all right well um i wanted to touch on
this article that i
read um because it helped me i guess
find
a little bit of uh empathy
i would say so this is a very long
article is published on the guardian
which say what you will about that news
outlet i don't know
uh it's by stephen marche or marky or
something it's called swallowing the red
pill a journey into the heart of modern
misogyny
so this is a man's outside take on
on the red pill community and he also
interviewed one of the main moderators
or whatever so it's a really long
article i suggest
you read it if you're interested but he
was saying um
just a little excerpts from the article
he was saying more than lust or hatred
the boys hunger for
clarity they desire escape from
confusion if you dig through the
misogyny and the bravado the boys still
want the one they are as lost in that
pursuit as every generation of men has
been before them
so what we're seeing is just a ton of
misogyny and women hatred and all this
stuff but what he's saying is he really
feels that underneath
they they all still really do just want
to like
be in love but they're confused on how
to deal with women like how
you know same with the extreme feminists
i think that like underneath it all
they they felt tricked almost by disney
movies
or whatever and they so they went
extremely the other way
but underneath i think maybe they i
think everyone wants love
yeah what do you think steve uh yeah i
mean i
i think if we if if you are were to take
a picture of a big crowd
and it's like a thousand people you
could point to a couple signs in the
crowd that are
shitty people but but unfortunately a
lot of news outlets and a lot of places
now
they like to just take those two signs
and go that's what this crowd's there
for that's what they're about
they're all like that and this guy
decided to go you know what
like what what's actually going on
behind the scenes here
and go figure he found there's a human
element to this
and that's what i don't find surprising
is that i think there's a human element
to all of this stuff that gets missing
when we just try to destroy each other
which is what our social media has
become why i hate labels because that
it's like when you put a label on
something you're saying that's an other
like that's not me that's not my box
that's another box and i'm just going to
label this group and i'm not going to
listen to them
because they're not in my box yeah and
not the whole crowd does not
is not represented by those two signs uh
so that's my
i it's a very frustrating thing to see
constantly happening to so many
different movements
i think it's happened to a more even
more of an extreme in the pandemic too
exactly because we're everyone's on
social media because you can't leave
your house
yeah and so everyone creates so many
boxes
well there's something to be said for
the way the technology was set up like
you have on twitter 280 characters now
like how can you really have a a real
representation of your idea like even if
you have
something to say you're going to say it
in the most kind of direct and snappy
way in order to get attention and i
noticed that because
um during the valentine's day thing a
lot of girls
were like why can't you just like you
know do something and i'm like yeah why
can't you just [ __ ] if your girl just
wants flat just show up with flowers
it's so small like why are men you hate
women like why
why can't you just do that but it's like
obviously the discussion is way longer
but twitter makes it to where like it's
easier for me to just type what do you
hate what's
the headline yeah so like the way the
technology set up is that the
discussions really aren't
there so social media makes it so much
easier to get so much
more radical so much faster because you
don't have there's
it's not the same as talking to someone
in person and what goes viral
is the quippy right headlines get hard
hit an emotion
yeah but i think that we need men and we
need men to be
men right now and i don't know
that there's a lot of places for them to
go to find out how to do that
well what do you think that equals a man
because i think it's even unclear to us
you're responsible for yourself being
accountable for yourself
and you know and then also being able to
protect the ones that you love
be like physically i think that and all
i mean by that is
unfortunately the bad ones that that are
out there when nikki goes walking
and like close to night she's worried
about the bad men out there so she won't
go walking unless i'm with her
so there's a reason why i as a man
have to be as strong as possible is
because there's shitty ones
that would do harm to her if i was not
there
and so that's what i mean by that is we
need to become men so that we can fight
the bad ones
uh and like there's a reason why like
you know um
guys are supposed to walk women to their
cars at night even if it's just your
friend they're over
you walk over to her car at night why
are you afraid of a
female jogger coming up with a knife
you're afraid of a guy you're afraid of
some crazy guy
trying to do something that you don't
want to have happen to you and so
the reason why we need to raise men as
men
is so that they understand how to
protect
the people that they love that's all
it's not because oh i'm such a badass
guy or anything like that
but is there any sort of impediment to
like guys
feeling like they want to protect women
like what like yeah all this
all this talk right like well i don't
need to
um you know get the door for her or any
of that [ __ ] that's all like
that's all patriarchal [ __ ] stuff
that
that that's why everything's [ __ ] up
right now okay so i guess
as a female myself when i hear that i'm
like oh well that's just like
10 girls believe that so i guess it's
it's the whole thing about
you're hearing the craziest like we're
hearing the craziest thing that men are
saying but they're hearing the craziest
thing that women yeah
because i don't personally believe that
it it belittles me whatsoever for a man
to open the door i expect i love it
i also open the door for people to it
just seems like a nice pretty
something to do there and people are
trying to get through and it's easier
for me to stand back hold the door open
yeah i'm gonna do that but
door walking on the outside right all
that stuff i just
it's all about like ultimately obviously
protection right
because we're trying to protect from the
bad guys
that's all it's not cause like you know
it's
it's not all bad stuff and like just
because this came from a
a time where like all this [ __ ] up
[ __ ] was happening to women it doesn't
mean that all the carry through
of it yeah is the same every element
right and i don't think
everyone thinks that but i just think
that that should be said more because
because we just go my god our world
our modern society was set up by these
patriarchal
all this [ __ ] and we don't look at some
of the good things that happen like how
everyone has a refrigerator
right now like you know what i mean like
we don't
look at like how like air conditioning
is
affordable for for people of like the
lowest income levels
like we instead just go like it's all
bad it's all because of bad and if you
go to vox or
any of that stuff you're just taught to
think that everything that happened
before now was bad
and you if you do that you will drive
people
reasonable people into dark places yeah
i even think like you know a lot of
those uh
those guys that are in this community
that go extreme and then you hear like
they do a manifesto and then they shoot
up a bunch of girls or like a sorority
or whatever
yeah um like it's like those it's those
guys that didn't get an
outlet now they they turn and and just
they start hating all women
it is the guy that you're protecting the
girl from on the way to the car
and that's why we i read that manifesto
it was very interesting it was crazy
yeah it happened in my hometown too
really yeah the elliot
barbara yeah yeah was it santa barbara
yeah
yeah it was a little bit strange because
he was angry that
okay so he was like maybe a little bit
understood anyhow
but no he he was very strange because
he was angry not that women rejected him
but he was angry because women didn't
approach him and hit on him
that was the thing he's like how can you
not hit on me i drive a bmw
yeah you came from a wealthy family yeah
but he was projecting if you watch the
video
you know that he doesn't think all that
[ __ ] but you can tell
obviously behind this facade this
bravado that he's projecting
he's really hurting because he can't get
with a chick and he doesn't understand
why he's like i got the car
so like why i got the watch i got the
car where are they coming now yeah
women aren't just goldfish too i mean
like they want you to have a personality
too there was evidence
for his false dichotomy and he could not
see it
right yeah he saw them going to the guy
that had more muscles than him
or like head whatever he saw the muscles
and the nice things but he didn't see
them
putting an effort and talking to the
woman and actually doing those things
wow the woman is off to you he had the
car he had the watch why isn't it
working
i mean because it doesn't work right it
could work on some people
sure no question but well there's
different there's so many different
reasons why different things work right
like
if if you're talking to one girl and
another girl like
the car in the watch thing might work
for this girl but it's not gonna work
for that girl yeah and then also for the
guy if the guy's attractive he might not
need the money but if the guy is
attractive
and he has money but his personality is
bad it's not gonna work on that girl so
there's
thousands of scenarios where different
combinations yeah
there's no rule for why something's
gonna work but that's why we gotta start
at the
at the building blocks right like be
responsible for yourself be accountable
like and then you know treat people with
respect
like obviously like like don't like
dunk on waiters and [ __ ] yeah you know
what i mean like
but there's a lot of that like i'm i'm
showing someone disrespect
so that i can show you that see i'm
confident
and strong and and it doesn't no one
likes that no one
but it's that idea that if i
can step on everything in this room i'm
showing you
that i have that i'm being the ability
yes look how big i am i'm stepping
what would you say to guys because i
know earlier you were talking about um
the physical
ability to protect women but i think
some of the guys
feel a little hurt because they're maybe
shorter
or they feel physically weaker
that and that women don't want them
because they can't
maybe physically protect them as well
and they they feel like
unworthy or whatever or they're meant to
feel unworthy because of that you can
always work on yourself
i mean there's look in ufc there's not
tallest guys in the world
there's a lot of like five six guys
that'll whoop some ass yeah
it's i mean bj penn was a short guy bart
quan
bark juan's the shortest guy i've ever
seen he's taken he's five tens
of leprechauns he's like people think
that anything under six foot
a woman won't want it that's not true
because a lot of women are five three
five four or five i know
i know it's not true but it's because
they see these there's dating profiles
like all over the place
six foot minimum six foot like you see
that stuff that's a meme but yeah i mean
i get that because like
of course when we're coming from a from
an angle of wanting to be protected
obviously our
number one first choice would be the
tallest the strongest the biggest the
richest the smartest like because we
want to be protected and we want our
offspring to be protected but
realistically when it comes down to it
like not
all of those things really matter yeah
like well you have a very mature way of
looking at this
where i if i am i'm an untrained not
that critical thinking person i see the
six foot meme
and i'm going see it's another piece of
proof that i cannot i have how do you
feel being over six foot
no it's incredible everyone should live
this way no
no it's look it that is not what gave me
confidence
right i got my confidence because i have
a very good understanding of who i am
and what i want out of life
and and i believe and i have strong
belief systems
and they give me confidence so that no
matter what room i'm in
i can be confident in what i think about
whatever the topic is
you have non-negotiables yes and i have
a bedrock of
just these i will not cheat on my wife i
will not you know
um emotionally cheat on my wife i will
not like all that stuff
gives me confidence there's that thing
um and i know a lot of people hate
jordan peterson and he brought him up
and i actually
i've listened to several hours of his
stuff because i wanted to know like is
this a good person or a bad person i
think he's a good person
his views may not agree with yours or
whatever but there's one thing he says
where he i think it's kind of like the
whole
um people are looking for freedom or
they
they value freedom but the real freedom
is is actually in
certain sacrifices because once you live
a life that's totally
just up for anything whatever i could
cheat i can whatever i can
then you're you start to get bogged down
by your addictions and you start to get
bogged down by
like there's there's so much everything
becomes meaningless yeah
so there's there is a freedom in
actually having responsibility
um sacrifice so like being married not
cheating on your wife like there's
there's like a freedom
and a purpose i like freedom within a
structure that's like how i like
everything in my life is even with
creativity like a blank canvas is so
hard to work with
but like here are some rules like draw a
piece of fruit i was like i could draw
that so many
ways but i but i now have a rule that
i'm like following i just i like that
structure like craving structure with
but then you get freedom within that
structure
yeah it seems like i mean what upsets me
the most about the current
state of men i guess is just
is is their access to the internet i
feel like has made
i do feel like has made them um weaker
because like
you know they don't really have to
approach women anymore they just go
online swipe and then we start to feel
like commodities and then we start
treating them like trash because they're
treating us like trash and it's just
creating a whole thing and it's like
when are they if they're running our
society are they going to just stop
this cycle of like treating women like
you know trash
but if they're running not the people
running society right these are
these guys are in dark corners for a
reason
there's nobody at the top reaching down
for their hand
right these these guys are left out and
that's why they feel
the need to act out and so
but i mean like the whole the dating
culture right where guys are just like
guys are wanting to get to a place a
point to where they're cool enough that
they can
treat women as replaceable objects so
like all the guys just want to be cool
enough have enough money so that like
when can i be cool enough to like just
pick up whatever chick i want and then
throw her away like that's what they're
striving for for some reason
and like that's what's bothering me
about men right now because i don't
think it was like that before
yeah i see a lot of these these nice guy
memes where
um it's like they were nice and the
girls don't want the nice guy
they want the [ __ ] well okay i need
to get to be the [ __ ] then
and then they see it as like well that's
what they want anyway
so they deserve to be treated like this
because like but they weren't nice just
to be nice
right they were nice for to get an
outcome yeah so it was transaction
i think a lot of those guys are in this
in this group in this red pool black
pill
group because they're like they just see
oh she chooses the [ __ ] constantly
over me
a nice guy so therefore i must i'm
i want to get to the point of being an
[ __ ] because that's what she wants
like the [ __ ]
is like he wants her for [ __ ] right
and that's transactional i tried to be
nice to get my transaction with her and
it was declined
yeah they don't see the irony of doing
something
like falsely to get an outcome yep
they're just
they're just working an angle mm-hmm and
they're a used car salesman who's just
got a better pitch but there's this
victimhood mentality
and all that that i feel like is
consistent in these groups
um any extremist group where it's like
it's like well i tried it my way and
they don't want
who i am like they're probably try i
mean it's like they they want the
the stupid bimbo that like like her
ultimate goal like is i just want to be
on a boat in the maldives or whatever
like so it's like i mean obviously you
don't have the tools to catch that fish
but like is that the fish that's really
good
there's no greater unfortunately there's
no greater
like enemy to confidence than having
that victim mentality that they're
having
right no it's it's funny because it's
like there's so many contradictions it's
like there's these all these guys that
say all women are gold diggers or what
they think there's a faction of them
that
think that all women want you for your
money but they're only going after women
who want money
right as soon as they get money then
they try to go get the gold diggers yeah
yeah exactly you you think that once you
have money and then women will just
flock to you and then the
women that are making their own money
they don't want them so it's like
okay you're only yeah it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy
we've all seen the awkward guy with the
luxury watch with the car
can't get chicks why because he's
awkward
you never developed anything else he's
not confident with himself
right and so having those building
blocks and being confident with yourself
will attract other people to you friends
like women men whatever like
people are attracted to confidence and
it does you don't have to be
you know bill gates is confident he's
not you know and he he i don't think he
had
any problem getting laid because bill
gates you
you when you hear him talk he's
interesting to listen to because he's
passionate about what he's talking about
yeah there have been many instances
where like at first i don't find someone
attractive then you get to know them
more and their confidence and yours like
holy crap
yeah you know and the height thing like
you like tim he's five foot what seven
yeah he carries himself like he's eight
foot two
i've had like two or three pretty short
boyfriends that were like under five
seven so
it's the b do have versus the have do be
so people
think in their minds that they have to
have the money first and then they can
have the things they want and be the
person they want to be
but really it's the opposite and when
you say confidence is key it's that's
really
that is the key it's so cliche but you
have to be do have you have to be the
confident person first
then you do the things that confident
people do because you have it within you
and then you have the things that
confident people have not the other way
around kevin hart's short as [ __ ] he's
like the biggest guy in every room
like it's just about having that
confidence it's not necessarily about
being the funniest it's not about being
whatever just being the most
authentically like whatever it is that
you like
a lot own it yeah own the [ __ ] out of it
there are guys out there with
garages filled with toy train sets who
get laid
i don't know how it works but they are
passionate about it right and they find
somebody else who's like you're so dumb
i can't i love that you love this they
find it cute and then like
they're like i'm gonna be painting this
weekend and they're like ah you
know what i mean it's just it just find
something that you're confident about
in yourself and build from there it's
attractive when people are passionate
about i love it
yeah look i found a youtube channel why
i listen to the guys talk about [ __ ]
pinball because they love it i don't
even give a [ __ ] about pinball
because it's interesting because they're
interested in it that's it yeah
women love passion people love passion
period i dated a dude who was super
passionate about yu-gi-oh cards
and that made me so happy yeah yeah i
think that's the thing is it's like
people aren't
go within yourself find your thing find
your thing that's attractive
i would like to close this out with a
little another little section of that
article that i
had referenced earlier he was saying um
that the what the boys of the red pill
need in all honesty is just a massive
dose of romantic poetry combined with
therapy they need to learn that love is
awful in both the ancient and modern
senses
and that love is indefinitely more
powerful and
real than any marketplace sexual or
otherwise they need to know that desire
is a mess and everyone suffers from its
mess
instead of culture the world offers the
red pill boys contempt
instead of education offers them outrage
but it's not just the boys of the red
pill who need to begin again to learn
it's everybody it's the whole world yeah
we need to balance out
for sure yeah oh well that was nice
yeah so i hope you feel heard you make
cowboys yeah you little mgtow boys you
want to go there away
[Applause]
where are they going
[Applause]
anyways um if you like this episode give
us five stars rate us whatever you guys
know the deal
hit the like button hit the subscribe
button share check out our sponsors
daryl dope
check out my podcast [ __ ] they don't
tell you oh yeah i guess you could what
else you got going on steve you've got a
crypto corner i've got a crypto corner
going on and me and nikki's patreon you
hear about my crypto my crypto moves
yeah and then sick crypto moves yeah
some sick crypto moves and then also
yeah i do my podcast with my lovely wife
here should they don't tell you
yeah yeah yes check us out all right
love you
thank you see you next week bye